il aura fallu plus de 4 ans pour que ce
centre commercial de Coignières fassent
pot neuve construit en 1987 avec
l'implantation de Castorama le forum
voit son attractivité déclinée quand
l'enseigne déménage aux portes de
Chevreuse mais reste propriétaire du
foncier nous avons eu à cette époque
l'envahissement du secteur par des gens
du voyage cette envahissement a duré
près de deux mois une situation qui
aurait dissuadé Truffaut de s'installer
au forum ne restait plus que Décathlon
sur les rangs pas suffisant pour lancer
des travaux de rénovation malgré
l'autorisation délivrée par la
commission départementale d'aménagement
commercial en 2011 le nombre d'enseignes
requis est atteint mais deux recours
successifs déposés par un riverain
freinent le projet finalement le
problème juridique est réglé la
rénovation peut alors reprendre
parcours et
toujours se met dans le bus il faut il
faut franchir toutes ces étapes
d'obtenir d'avoir la CDAC ensuite de
tenir le permis donc voilà tout ça prend
du temps et puis de commercialiser
auprès des enseignes dans les périodes
actuelles elles sont pas toutes enclin
é de manière récurrente on va dire donc
voilà c'est ça qui est difficile le
promoteur indépendant sopique spécialisé
dans l'urbanisme commercial à un vesti
20 millions d'euros dans le projet 14000
m² de terrain vont être totalement
repensés avec la construction d'un
bâtiment Haute Qualité Environnementale
niveau emploi le nouveau forum devrait
permettre une centaine d'embauches mais
aussi de redynamiser le secteur et c'est
important également pour l'image de la
commune nous avons un secteur à l'entrée
de ville qui est actuellement je dirais
en grande difficulté qui a besoin d'être
qualifiée qui a besoin d'être réhabilité
de rénover d'être rénové et donc ça pour
la commune c'est très important cette
opération voit le jour la zone de
chalandise représente 360 000 habitants
datent prévus de fin des travaux juin
2013 devrait suivre l'ouverture des
enseignes à la rentrée de septembre
quatre ont déjà signé